efe
no solamente de william de presentar el
gamescom
el día 9 de mayo de 2017 el presidente
de los eeuu donald trump despidió al
entonces director del fbi james cómic
que en aquel momento conducía una
investigación para determinar si los
asesores de donald trump conspiraron
junto al gobierno ruso durante la
campaña presidencial de 2016
[Música]
en los días posteriores tal y como ha
revelado el 'new york times' el fbi y
comenzó a investigar si el mismísimo
presidente de los eeuu donald trump es
un agente al servicio de rusia que
trabaja contra los intereses
estadounidenses y si supone un peligro
para la seguridad nacional
[Aplausos]
[Música]
vamos a ver teóricamente la influencia
de rusia en el mundo tendría que ser
cada vez más pequeña no nos parece al
fin y al cabo hablamos de un país muy
corrupto que con unos 145 millones de
habitantes tiene una economía más
pequeña que la del estado de texas y que
además vive en una especie de
estancamiento crónico vamos que apenas
crece sin embargo queridos amigos de
visual política espera hace un momento
porque a la hora de la verdad
prácticamente no hay en todo el mundo un
solo conflicto o problema político donde
la rusia de vladimir putin no esté
metida de lleno casi siempre hay contra
los intereses de las potencias
occidentales todo se ha dicho
[Música]
no me creéis pues solo tenéis que pensar
en la posición de rusia respecto a
venezuela cuba siria irán ucrania donde
incluso se anexionaron cream ya en las
elecciones de eeuu etcétera etcétera y
todo ello por no hablar de cosas como
estas ex espía ruso envenenado con un
agente nervioso en la puerta de su casa
en inglaterra
[Música]
y es que amigos gracias sobre todo a su
enorme arsenal nuclear ya todos sus
recursos naturales
en política exterior vladimir putin hace
prácticamente lo que le da la gana y
como esto es algo que ya tiene muy pero
que muy harto los líderes occidentales
es aquí cuando surge una gran pregunta o
mejor dicho la gran pregunta cómo
diantres frenar a vladimir putin o al
menos cómo reducir su influencia en el
mundo amigos esto es lo que hoy se
preguntan en muchas capitales pero sobre
todo en washington atentos
el castigo
y en la hace la paga para evitar que lo
vuelva a hacer está amigos es la
respuesta de washington veréis desde
hace cuatro años desde la invasión de
crimea las relaciones de rusia con eeuu
y sus aliados han estado dominadas por
las sanciones y los castigos económicos
y políticos y ojo porque contra esto no
ha sido diferente más bien todo lo
contrario la administración trump ha
impuesto muchas sanciones a rusias
durante los últimos dos años las
sanciones siguen vigentes y permanecerán
vigentes hasta que se produzca el cambio
requerido en el comportamiento ruso john
bolton pero claro dicho esto antes de
avanzar nos tenemos que hacer una
pregunta que estoy seguro muchos os
habéis hecho ya realmente sirven para
algo tomas estas sanciones pues veréis
si y no me explico la economía rusa está
sufriendo por ellas eso es algo que está
bastante claro y no es que lo diga solo
el fondo monetario internacional
alexei kudrin un importantísimo político
ruso ministro de finanzas entre el 2000
y el 2011 un personaje bastante cercano
a putin y que hoy es jefe de la cámara
de cuentas defiende que uno de los
principales objetivos de la política
exterior de su país tiene que ser lograr
que se suavicen las sanciones
internacionales porque de otro modo los
objetivos económicos de putin no se van
a cumplir
vamos que la economía rusa lo va a pasar
mal pero claro en todo esto hay un
problema a vladimir putin que la
economía rusa marche mejor o peor pues
digamos que para él no es lo más
importante sin embargo amigos si hay dos
campos que para él son imprescindibles y
ojo porque en washington lo saben y ya
han empezado a atacar uno de ellos
atentos
[Música]
el complejo industrial-militar russo
vale estoy seguro de que no voy a
sorprender a nadie si digo que tanto la
política como la economía rusa están muy
pero que muy vinculadas al poder militar
sin embargo hasta qué punto pensáis que
es importante la industria militar rusa
pues amigos aunque mucho más pequeño que
el tiempo de la unión soviética el
complejo industrial-militar ruso sigue
siendo gigantesco por ejemplo da empleo
a casi tres millones de personas
es decir ni más ni menos que 1 de cada
20 empleos en rusia depende de la
industria militar puestos de trabajo
industriales que suelen tener tasas de
productividad muy altas y ojo estamos
hablando de empleos directos sin tener
por supuesto en cuenta a los propios
soldados del ejército ruso así que
imaginaos la gigantesca influencia que
la industria militar tiene en la
sociedad y en la política de este país
[Música]
de hecho tan solo las 10 mayores
empresas de fabricación de armamento
militar de rusia facturan cada año casi
40 mil millones de dólares y esto es
mucho dinero hoy por hoy en todo el
planeta tan solo la industria militar de
eeuu es más grande pero además para
vladimir putin la industria militar rusa
es fundamental por más motivos
i
primero por ser una enorme fuente de
divisas veréis rusia es también el
segundo mayor exportador de armas de
todo el planeta entre el año 2000 y el
año 2017 las exportaciones de armas
rusas supusieron el 25 por ciento de
todas las exportaciones de armas en todo
el mundo para que nos hagamos una idea
más de 100 mil millones de dólares
[Música]
en segundo lugar la venta de equipos
militares es tal vez la estrategia más
efectiva de la política exterior de
rusia gracias a semejante capacidad
industrial rusia puede ganarse el favor
de países como venezuela que dependen
del armamento ruso o puede mejorar sus
relaciones con otros a cambio de
tecnología militar como es el caso de
china o la india
[Música]
y por último junto a los empleos las
divisas y el poder político está la
propia financiación del ejército ruso
vladimir putin paga los planes de
modernización del ejército ruso con las
ventas de armas al resto del mundo por
no hablar de que la rusia fuerte que
vende putin no tendría ningún sentido si
no fueran capaces de producir muchas
armas
[Música]
dicho de otro modo dañar el complejo
industrial-militar ruso le supondría al
país una enorme crisis económica perder
su capacidad de modernizar el ejército y
gran parte de su influencia política en
el mundo pues bien el caso es que todo
esto en washington lo saben por eso los
últimos paquetes de sanciones se han
dirigido particularmente hacia el
complejo militar causándole muchos
problemas
[Música]
por ejemplo tanto eeuu como la unión
europea han restringido la venta de
muchos equipos y componentes
tecnológicamente avanzados ojo no solo
componentes militares también otros que
pueden ser utilizados tanto para fines
civiles como para fines militares y no
penséis que hablamos de poca cosa tan
solo la unión europea le vendía a rusia
20 mil millones de dólares cada año
de momento las empresas rusas han
tratado de mirar hacia china pero claro
no es lo mismo y eso es algo que afecta
a la efectividad del armamento ruso y
por tanto al interés de los compradores
pero ahí no queda todo las sanciones
aprobadas implican que por ejemplo eeuu
podría llegar a sancionar a responsables
políticos y empresarios que compren
armamento ruso lo que igual a un
venezolano le es indiferente pero a
personas de otros países eso ya puede
hacerles cambiar de opinión
[Música]
eeuu impuso sanciones a una agencia
estatal china responsable de comprar
armamento extranjero las armas en
cuestión fueron suministradas por rusia
ahora bien esto es lo que se ha hecho lo
que ahora algunos expertos plantean en
washington es ir aún mucho más allá como
pues amigos la clave está en los
clientes de la industria militar rusa
veréis durante los últimos años los
mejores clientes de rusia han sido la
india china y vietnam tan sólo las
exportaciones militares a la india
vietnam han supuesto el 45 por ciento de
todas las exportaciones militares de
rusia durante los últimos cuatro años
casi la mitad así que me da que ahora
vais a entender noticias como estas
obama levanta el embargo de eeuu de
ventas de armas letales a vietnam eeuu
reconoce a la india como su mayor socio
en defensa
lockheed martin se asocia con data para
fabricar cazas f-16 en la india
[Música]
y aún más los países árabes con la
excepción de egipto han reducido sus
compras de equipos rusos las nuevas
sanciones a irán tampoco le van a dar
mucho margen a este país y otros
compradores importantes como venezuela
pues han dejado de serlo
además hay otra idea que se empieza a
barajar en washington y es que para los
compradores con menos presupuestos la
industria militar ucraniana podría ser
un duro rival para las empresas rusas
especialmente si reciben el apoyo de los
países de la otan sí sí no es ninguna
locura mirad el 15 por ciento de toda la
producción militar soviética se hacía en
ucrania este país hoy sigue siendo el
undécimo mayor exportador de armamento
de todo el planeta e incluso hasta el
año 2013 continúa siendo un
importantísimo proveedor de la mismísima
rusia en otras palabras en washington ya
muchos expertos defienden que
facilitando la venta de armas a los
compradores de equipos rusos e
impulsando la industria militar
ucraniana se le podría asestar un duro
golpe a vladimir putin eeuu a prueba
posible venta de misiles patriot a
turquía como apuesta para bloquear la
compra a rusia y amigos aún nos queda el
petróleo
i
la sangre de la madre de rusia
no hay dudas la economía rusa es muy
pero que muy dependiente del petróleo y
el gas natural y como ya hemos visto
aquí en visual político rusia es un
proveedor esencial para los países de la
unión europea y eso no va a cambiar es
muy triste que alemania haga un acuerdo
masivo de gas y petróleo con rusia
mientras se supone que tú debes
protegerlos frente a moscú y alemania
bayless paga miles y miles de millones
de dólares al año a rusia donald trump
pero cuidado a corto y medio plazo un
precio del barril del petróleo por
debajo de los 60 dólares y menos compras
de gas por parte de los países de la
unión europea haría que rusia tuviera
muchas pero que muchas dificultades para
financiar sus planes de modernización
militar
ahora bien evidentemente la primera
pregunta es cómo mantener un precio del
petróleo por debajo de 60 dólares pues
básicamente impulsando las nuevas
fuentes de producción si estoy hablando
del fracking y eso es lo que está
haciendo eeuu no sólo ni principalmente
por el conflicto con rusia evidentemente
pero está ocurriendo
[Música]
la otra cuestión es como hemos dicho
haciendo que la unión europea' compre
menos gas a rusia como pues
fundamentalmente impulsando el gas
natural licuado que permite por ejemplo
que países como australia o eeuu puedan
vender su gas por todo el mundo puede
ser más caro pero una reducción de las
compras no sería algo nada pero que nada
bueno para moscú la unión europea está
lista para facilitar más importaciones
de gas natural liquado de eeuu y este es
ya el caso mientras hablamos con claude
juncker presidente de la comisión
europea seguro que ahora entonces a
entender mucho mejor
muchos de los sucesos de la actualidad
internacional pues bien es que además
amigos ahora si se quiere hacer es el
momento
es el momento
la popularidad de vladimir putin en
rusia se ha hundido en los últimos dos
años como consecuencia de la mala
situación económica y la falta de
avances su popularidad ha perdido ni más
ni menos que más de 30 puntos y no es
extraño fijaos
en dólares el salario medio de los rusos
fue más bajo en 2018 que en 2008 es
decir hoy los rusos tienen menos
capacidad de compra de productos
internacionales desde que putin se hizo
con crimea
las cosas no han ido bien y según una
encuesta del centro levada el 61% de los
rusos considera que putin es plenamente
responsable de los problemas que
atraviesa el país
precisamente por esto amigos en
washington son muchos los que piensan
que este es el momento para atacar a
putin y todo apunta a que la casa blanca
y el departamento de estado han comprado
esta idea funcionará el tiempo nos dirá
amigos si este vídeo se ha resultado
interesante no olvidéis darle a like y
suscribiros abisal político un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]
james comer
y
[Música]